was ist der duden wörterbuch zeigt euch
das ihr von herzen kommen zu einem neuen
video jagd vielen dank heute schon wie
der ablauf man einfach immer noch übel
geworden ich habe mich heute die
eigentlichen im büro vor ort spuren und
da ist er ja und leute wie zogen heute
ein neues spiel aus dem google places
und zwar das wer wird millionär spiel
habe ich so schon mal locker gesehen
lukas wie es in dem schreiben verlinkt
sturm ist wie gesagt heute dabei wir
werden jeweils ein waren durchmachen
gucken wer am meisten kohle macht sagen
dann einfach ob es jetzt mehr ist als
wir gerade mit youtube verdient
selbstständig auch ihm du hast deine
kontoauszüge auch alles okay leute ich
fange jetzt acht mal hier ein neues
spiel stunden mit rein du denkst du auch
deine antworten und lass mich einfach
aus um eine falsche absolut ich kenne
alles ein hamburger von mcdonald's heißt
schmeckt ja muss ich mich erstmal big
mac alter als ob und welchen teil des
körpers gehört das trommelfell nasa auf
jeden fall in hasenfeld existiert mund
fällt telefonanrufen leute diese frage
ist 2000 euro wert wenn ich jemals in
meinem leben 2000 euro einfach so leicht
zu kommen hätte dann wäre sie über
geworden hierbei war schon ziemlich
erfolg eigentlich auch bereit wenn er
fällt dann fällt das ist eine logische
und ich weiß es nicht falsch wenn er
fällt dann sinkt ja ok taste leute 2000
euro warum gibts eigentlich bis drei
millionen aud dass das spiel wer wird
drei millionen
von wer wird millionär es gut geht lebt
wie die made im speck sacrum ernsthaft
das hätte zum beispiel es wieder nicht
gewusst wer sprichwörter weiß ich gar
nicht wie ich leute hier sind welche
verderben den kuchen den kur den
momenten aber ein buch muss man nicht
kochen oder habe ich schon mal fast
schon klar video bekommt ihr verderben
natürlich in dem fall den drei leute ich
hätte 5000 das ist das hart verdiente
5030 sie auch getan wenn ich dicker
junge das ist so riegler weltalter wie
viele spieler in der wirtschaft sind
beim ok ich leute wie nennt man einen
senkrechtstart das fluggerät
segelflugzeug haberzettl ihn geht doch
auch das ist ja völlig schwierigen frage
über zeppelin kann's ja losgehen wenn
der aufgeblasene punkte ja auch wo
champion oder luftballons schraube hoch
schreibt jung ist haye 15.000 euro
alltag weiter woraus besteht das
wattenmeer wartet wasser und meer
der küste wasser und schlamm nichts
bleibt wie es ist
an der küste wo gerade noch unendliche
smart war tobt ein paar stunden später
wasser und schlamm wasser und schlamm
leute kann ich als gestandener oder aber
sagen da mails 120000 euro erhältlich
auch wieder nicht muss das dreifachen
ich hätte jetzt tatsächlich gesagt
wasser nur wasser ist ja klar dass
solche nicht normal aber jetzt ist
tricky so dass keine tipps genug auf
diese chance mich absolut wirklich keine
ahnung auch kann ich mir so ehrlich
sagen ich kann die wirklichkeit weil ich
keine ahnung haben ersteres ist es raus
jetzt nicht ich bin jetzt in der gefahr
auf 5000 autos fand ich sagte mir dass
das einzige spiel das mit meiner oma
damals gespielt hat bittet ja mein gott
hast du absolut nicht aber ich hab mal
gesagt weil das war das einzige das ich
kenne
oh mein gott
mit was bin ich jetzt raus mit 5000 euro
können wir dank der man ihr allerdings
mit 5000 euro machen
das ist ein zwanzigstel ok 5000 euro für
mich ich habe auf jeden fall beruht
alles verkackt jetzt ist an dir zu
zeigen aus jedem auf was was ist der
duden wörterbuch zeit
danach galt der vater von zwei jungen
vergangen zu tun ich habe keine jogger
verwendet möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen würde mein gott ich
habe schon eine frage ist so viel glück
ich hatte sammelte geld möchte man
machen wenn sie hier irgendwelche monat
ist ein kurzes euro ist natürlich auch
nicht
ich will einfach an der stelle marine
anrufen kurz gucken was er dazu sagt
felix das könnte telefon gesagt
februar halten welche bahn fährt mich
auf schienen straßen waren irgendwann
eisenbahn hoffen
nachbarn haben wir daraus macht u bahn
aber denkt man da etwas fährt in straße
fährt auto fährt nur eisen kann man
einen spaß daraus machen
original vernünftigste reaktion auf
eisen autobahn als auch ohne sandra
absolut richtig ob es jetzt kommen die
schnüffel sachen du hast halt 5000 ich
muss nur über 5000 wer besonders tief
schläft du dies redensartlich wie ein
schlag was ist ein was ist ein in
westkanada was ist ein erstes wort ich
wollte mich falsch ausspricht
das kann keine ahnung ich würde an der
stelle einfach mal den publikumstagen
murmeltier schläft den piraten das ist
denn jetzt eigentlich nichts weiter vom
tisch hängt davon ab wie weit man
entwirft und jetzt aber die frage
wirklich stammt oder baum ich weiß echt
nicht richtig weiß halt wenn ich richtig
hilft die macht ist der apfel fällt
nicht weit vom baum macht aber sinn weil
fulham haben wollen nee du vor
unterschiedlich sagt stamm war richtig
jetzt gibt's gleich dann die cd aber
jeder soll fragen wie welches dieser
tiere gehört zu den bremer statt
das ist koscher fährt oder elefanten
ich sagte dass ich mein gott wichtig
halten hat einst ganz als ob immer wenn
ja hat stehe weiß ich nicht ich muss
echt wenn anrufen ich möchte mich
anrufen
wie viele karten warum ich denn da nach
höheren alter ich denke die antwort ist
der sagt de ich sagte ich vertraue
meinen karten frage beantwortet der
jetzt bin ich wieder alleine bei welcher
sportler gibt es das sparring boxen
schaffen
die basketball oder fußball ich sagt
boxen alter ich weiß dass ich sie durch
die putts liebt seine mutter
er war deutete eine noch eine noch
welches lied ist nicht von udo jürgens
dein ist mein ganzes herz merci cherie
aber bitte mit sahne
ich fragte publikum guckt mir die leute
mal an dein ist mein ganzes herz sagt
das abkommen
ich hatte im publikum auf welches land
liegt auf dem gleichen kontinent wie die
türkei das weiß ich wirklich nicht mal
wie war die vielleicht kontinent weißt
du das was du am kontinent erstmal erste
folge x 2 locker was wann immer ich 50
50 chance war liedern das passiert jetzt
optimal zwei jogger erzählte man falsch
antwortet jetzt wird eifrig in die figur
welche farbe hat grobi aus der
sesamstraße nur grobi kein planiger
wirklich nein ich habe wirklich auch
keine ampel noch mal machen raten also
bei sesamstraße die arbeiten die haben
das durch sachen die dann so also
visuell sind auch wenn man jemand grob
ist dann übrigens einen rot blau 100000
euro ist leider natürlich weniger als
12.000 müssen wir alleine war aber
trotzdem gut geschlagen aber okay leute
sollen einfach nicht mir ich habe
verkackt aufgrund meine eigene dummheit
schön dass du dabei warst nicht so dumm
was ist werde ich richtig und verlinkt
leute wissen nicht mal macht's gut